martine gayraud que j'avais pas vu
depuis longtemps je vous salue martin
bonjour michel david christian dufour
bonsoir bonsoir soit une période de
questions
qui me fait penser aux périodes de
questions et que monsieur bouchard des
fois quelqu'un ça s'enflamme mais à
l'époque on faisait 3 topo et trois
versions des systèmes à carburant les
périodes de questions c'est on sait
moins comme ça que celle là est
intéressante mais en moins je fais
entendre tout de suite le premier
extrait madame anglade qui attaquent sur
le 6 milliards des garderies en termes
sur le go n'allait pas laisser 6
milliards sur la table pourquoi vous
dites fois primé sur le tour ça nous
prend des places avez-vous l'argent pour
les places on écoute pour rien je pense
pas qu'ils tentaient de nous dire qu'on
ne comprend pas les champs de compétence
tout évidemment par contre c'est de pas
de mettre genou à terre pour passer les
6 milliards de dollars parce que des 6
milliards de dollars je pense que c'est
une très bonne entente pour les familles
du québec que trois partis qui veulent
entrer d'un champ de compétence du
québec qui veulent pas nous donner
pouvoir protéger le français qui veulent
pas nous donner pouvoir protéger nos
valeurs
nous on n'accepte pas ça si le parti
libéral est prêt à se vendre au plus
offrant et ses choix du parti libéral le
leader de son parti
il y aurait des justin trudeau a préparé
ces débats donc c'est qu'ils vrai patron
du leader
ce fortin député libéral à québec qui a
aidé monsieur trudeau dans un groupe
pour préparer le dernier débat en
français martin c'est toute une rentrée
en matière on est tous muscles à québec
frais et dispos qu'est ce que vous êtes
prêts pour l'année électorale ça c'est
certain et c'est l'occasion pour les
partis d'opposition surtout de se
démarquer surtout que différentes
positions ça va être une session
garderie fort probablement parce qu'il
va se passer beaucoup de choses oui le 6
milliards de dollars à ottawa cette
entente entre monsieur legault et
monsieur trudeau pour compléter le le
réseau des garderies mais également pour
compenser le québec parce que le québec
est déjà fort avancé alors avec la
balance si on n'a pas besoin au québec
de ce 6 milliards le au complet monsieur
legault pourrait l'utiliser ailleurs les
partis d'opposition vont se démarquer
sur ce point là en disant ben monsieur
legault en prenant pour les bleus il n'y
a pas prononcé les conservateurs
aujourd'hui et il est sur la table cet
argent si utile et en année électorale
c'est certain que tous les partis vont
vouloir courtiser les familles c'est
elle en euros mais monsieur non
seulement et louis michel avait il dit
oui je suis bleu puis il ya les bleus on
est national et les ja du parti
québécois vous et moi on est les seuls
ici à défendre la nation du québec dont
qui était hilare mais non seulement ils
reculent pris la relève oui l'art mais
je pense qu'il voit très bien le ski est
en train de se dessiner c'est à dire que
plus on voit les sondages plus la
perspective d'un gouvernement libéral
minoritaire
probablement avec l'appui du du npd
c'est le pire scénario ça pour monsieur
pour monsieur legault alors on sait que
ça l'inquiète mais ce qui m'a frappé le
plus pendant cette période de questions
là si on aborder bien sûr des dossiers
québec au québec moi je faisais bon les
places en garderie
l'élite est râpé le troisième billet
mais c'est qu'en arrière fond il y avait
toujours la campagne fédérale à chaque
fois on y revenait d'une manière ou
d'une autre la on a vu des changes le
monsieur legault qui dit que
madame libéraux sont prêts à vendre leur
âme pour 6 milliards libéraux disent
legault s'agenouille devant un
conservateur à chaque fois on finissait
par revenir à la campagne fédérale est
ce moi je prévois que bien au delà de
l'élection la relation que les parties
au québec vont avoir avec l'éventuel
futur gouvernement que ce soit qu'ils
soient pour ou contre vatin été beaucoup
la prochaine année évidemment il valide
aussi proprement québécois mais les
relations fédérales-provinciales nous
avons vont prendre une classe assez
assez grand kiciak est ce que vous avez
pensé de cette période
je trouve que monsieur legault persiste
et signe comme vous l'avez dit c'est
très clair en fait j'ai dans le dossier
de la défense poire québécois et il a
raison sur ce dossier spécifique là de
dire que les conservateurs
historiquement interviennent beaucoup
moins dans les champs de compétence
provinciaux que les libéraux bon il
prend le risque c'est audacieux en fait
la prise de position qui l'a adopté moi
je trouve qu'au québec on n'est plus
tellement dans l'audace et le risque
donc c'est pas étonnant entre autres que
ça a choqué beaucoup de monde mais au
fond comme michel le dis si les libéraux
sont élus minoritaires puis rien ne soit
encore si on leur a pris l'eau mais
c'est si les libéraux sont élus
minoritaires c'est clair que ça augure
patel mardié pour la relation de slogans
des libéraux mais pour les garderies ces
gagnants parce que si les libéraux
l'emportent des chiffres ronds points
d'entente sur les garderies parce que
monsieur tous les deux battus le monial
j'appelle au rêve est dans la poche et
quant à monsieur autour monsieur legault
réussi quelque chose là lui aussi au
tour envoyé à monsieur legault c'est
très inédit ce service et des paroles
s'envolent les écrits restent l'argent
lui même la lettre qu'ils ont publiées
monsieur monsieur autour s'avance quand
même pas mal quand c'est qu'on va se
rencontrer dans les 100 premiers jours
je reconnais que le stade québécois et
sera donc je trouve que monsieur legault
plus gagner quelque chose que prévu même
si près c'est clair qui prend un risque
on n'est pas habitué à ça en fait les
gens révolue qui s'annonce pas autant
mais oui mais ça vous êtes un peu parce
que joe faire entendre un autre extrait
ou en répondant au parti québécois on
est parti mais quand il dit vous avez
rien obtenu monsieur legault bout du
général mais attention hélas
rappelez vous il vient de dire que les
rouges c'est une respecte pas on a rien
c'est difficile oui il fait la liste de
tous qui a obtenu avec monsieur trudeau
on écoute sans condition on a eu un
point 8 milliards pour le logement sans
conditions ni 6 milliards sans condition
que les services de garde on n'a eu qu'à
30 ans sur la formation de la main
d'oeuvre on a eu 600 millions en
aéronautique on a eu 460 millions
internet au du test
374 millions pour les demandeurs d'asile
on ne règle et la gestion de l'offre on
a fait une lutte à l'itinérance ont
obtenu 172 millions on a obtenu 3
milliards pour la relance et que guitare
sans condition
martin vient de dire être trudeau j'ai
rien passé ils sont pas ils respectent
pas la nation québécois plainte fait
l'analyse de tout ce qu'ils ont reçu moi
je les note émotions parce qu'un
paradoxe dans ce qu'il dit parce que il
dit il ya c'est vrai que monsieur
trudeau propose d'imposer des normes en
santé tchité rome et mais il dans sa
liste u10 très souvent que c'est sans
condition alors il est négociable
monsieur trudeau où un certain écart
alors c'est c'est vrai qu'il ya un
paradoxe dans l'ensemble du tour de
table là dessus j'ai passé une semaine
ça va frapper michel qui quand il l'a
fait salissures pq ça nous a pas frappés
avec ce qu'avait dit juste avant bah oui
intérêt à se disait pourquoi il
recommande pas de voter trudeau voit ça
à ce compte là mais je pense que
monsieur legault est quand même un
comptable c'est aussi en élargissant le
portrait un peu
le 6 % ce comprend que c'est pas ce que
demandent les provinces mais l'eau 6%
d'augmentation par année que monsieur
autour des prêts à consentir aux
provinces si on met ça sur une période
le moindrement la longue c'est plus que
tout ce que monsieur legault a énuméré
et qu'on ajoute le 4 milliards que
présumément les conservateurs
accepterait de payer pour le troisième
ne vient au total c'est pas mal plus que
ce que monsieur trudeau à consentir au
cours des deux trois dernières années et
mai et on sait ce qu'on a eu ça qu'on
pût c'est ce qu'on va avoir la pression
mais ceci étant dit c'était assez
bizarre d'entendre
les inondations
ben moi je suis moins tonique vous
autant fait de ça parce que c'est le
sans condition qui est important c'est
que tout ce qu'il a obtenu sans
conditions je comprends qu'il s'en vante
très bien mais le moment de monsieur
trudeau envoie un message très clair à
l'effet qu'il va intervenir dans les
champs de compétence provinciaux le
message est clair comme de l'eau de
roche donc ce
monsieur moi c'est ça c'est que pas
assez monsieur legault six braqueurs du
tout sauf d'après ce que je comprends
c'est sans conditions pourquoi s'en
vanterait pas mais il reste dans le
domaine de la santé monsieur trudeau le
dire et redire dit on va avoir des
conditions donc monsieur legault ça
puisse vraiment dans ce lac du parquet
doit sinon moi moi je serais très mal à
l'aise par rapport à son état boissons
pour être parce que dans un système
fédéral ces deux niveaux de compétence
normalement on n'embarque pas dans le
terrain de l'eau mais monsieur legault
en bas sur le terrain respectez donc
compétents sont bons je trouve que sa
défense elle se défend beaucoup plus que
bien des gens le disent très bien très
bien
monsieur trudeau si jamais il remporte
une minorité
lundi je recommence avec vous christian
tour de table rapide qu'elle quel genre
de relations et de rapport de force il
va avoir avec monsieur legault à ce
moment
rappelons que pour les garderies on va
avoir le 6 milliards c'est clair non
mais c'est vrai pour le dis quand même
pour le reste dans le domaine de la
santé c'est quand il y aura là sans
seront pas d'amour temps mais
mais ils sont tellement en opposition
solide aussi identitaire c'est difficile
d'être plus ans d'opposition que ça
rappelons que quand on ne brûlait des
niveaux canada monsieur trudeau pas été
capable de le dénoncer puis monsieur
legault a dit que c'était atroce ce
genre de choses là dans le domaine de la
santé monsieur monsieur trudeau je veux
imposer les conditions donc les
relations seront pas très très bonne
mais il reste moins de jeu doit
fonctionner et 6,6 pour poursuivre mon
argumentaire de tantôt parce que le
dossier de l'arrivée respect des
compétences du québec et beaucoup dans
l'arène politique
dsk michèle dawe est sur la même ligne
monsieur legault ne veut pas placer
madame anglade en contradiction pile
parti libéral du québec parti libéral du
canada les les champs de compétence est
ce que il ne place pas dans ma peau
l'ata pour sa campagne à l'huile tout à
fait mais madame anglade est très
consciente qu'il faut qu'elles se
situent disons sur un registre beaucoup
plus nationaliste que le parti libéral d
année dernière mais dans une surenchère
de nationalisme pur je me suis monsieur
le groupe sis à un moment donné avait
frappé le mur mais pour revenir à la
question que vous posez à christian les
relations entre les deux ça risque
d'être difficile parce que je regardais
l'extrapolation de sièges que philippe
fournier et faisaient tantôt si on
additionne les je pense à 146 pour les
libéraux mais trente deux néo démocrates
alors monsieur trudeau va pouvoir
s'appuyer sur le npd pour faire avancer
son son programme centralisateur et
aussi son programme comment dire
multiculturaliste alors c'est que c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle alors
qu'inversement même si les conservateurs
avec les sièges qu'ex japonais fournier
qui on ajoutait ceux du bloc ils
n'arrivent pas à la main
assez confortable pour beaucoup mais ya
manque en amalgamant comme 4 martin un
petit mot ça va quand même être plus
facile si minoritaire que si majoritaire
mais mais pour rebondir sur ce que
michel disait un petit peu plus tôt
quel que soit le résultat de lundi
prochain ça va avoir un impact sur les
débats à québec les relations
québec-ottawa bon c'est éviter pour la
prochaine session complètement l'oeil et
déjà le parti québécois a commencé la
poser des questions sur les convictions
profondes de monsieur legault qu'est-ce
qui a l'intention de faire allez-vous
redevient souveraine svc sa savoie se
poser la question quel que soit le
résultat oui ça me fait sourire et une
science oui je vous savez audrey qui
déchaîne souverainisme et y est
franchement nationaliste c'est un bleu
ça rappelle de vieux vieux vieux
souvenirs cela dit pour madame engage
tous une catastrophe en fait la nouvelle
que son leader parlementaire participé à
la préparation du débat de monsieur
trudeau fortin me dis qu'ils
interviendraient d' qui est avérée d'un
compétence provinciale ça amène beaucoup
sa crise il acquiesce multi touch parti
libéral comme des français du pouvoir
québécois jusqu'aux mineurs
sera très forte est-ce que c'était une
erreur pour lui d'aller donner ses
services à l'équipe de monsieur trudeau
basso décisive il avait fait la même
chose en 2019
souvenez vous au printemps le tout le
monde se demandait il va tu allais se
présenter au fédéral ou s'ils vont
rester
au niveau québécois
honnêtement pour moi c'est pas une
surprise c'est une gaffe je suis
d'accord parce que ça paraît mal ça
contredit le discours de sa chef mais
monsieur fortin celui-ci fait partie de
l aile la plus fédéraliste du caucus
libéral à québec
alors moi je suis pas surpris de ses
convictions s'exprime comme ça mais dans
les circonstances et c'est évident que
c'était une bourde oui martine quand
c'est vrai mais bon si je pense que
c'est une erreur et d'ailleurs sa
réponse en deal parce qu'il s'est
enfargé il ya dit
n'importe quel chef qui aurait voulu me
servir sur lui redonner je vois très mal
le monsieur
françois blanchet alors ça démontrait
qui est un peu pris dans les câbles puis
qui essayait de se dépatouiller avec
celui qui répond généralement c'est
clairement question mais parce que le
plq ne veut pas être vue comme la
succursale du bien c'est sûr surtout au
mois main où il s est dit sur la
question des compétences et c est
monsieur legault était passablement
batailleur là dessus il savait tout de
s'affairer j'avais sorti nous et on va
en 20 sorties les extras auraient en
temps pour ceux qui ont manqué le tout
début de l'émission déco qui vrai patron
du leader
est ce que c'est la chef de l'opposition
officielle c'est justin trudeau c'est
qu'ils sont patents est-ce qu'il ya 10 à
justin trudeau pour voulait pas
d'ingérence dans nos compétences est ce
que dit à justin trudeau pour voulait
protéger le français qu'anglais protéger
nos valeurs du président vous aurez
remarqué que au dessus de vous il n'ya
plus de croyez plus de crucifier qu'à
quitter le salon but on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir un premier ministre qui joue un
rôle de curés comme en 1950 pour dire
aux gens comment penser et pour qui
voter monsieur le président je vais
conseiller n'importe quel chef de parti
qui nous le demandent ça a été le cas en
2009 c'était quand corps de métier
les deux cas c'est toujours la même
le crucifix pour elle que celui qui est
parti on va pas
ce débat là christian mais c'est
intéressant certaines périodes de
questions intéressantes succès intéresse
vous trouvez ça se trouve évidemment
garderie je veux revenir aux garderies
on va écouter monsieur o toole parce que
on en a parlé rapidement il incrimine
lettre au premier du québec indien jouët
par là pour les 100 premiers jours où
sauf que son cadre financier l'a pas
sauvé la chèvre et le chou il envoie des
crédits d'impôts il les paie avec une
partie de l'argent qu'il libère ou
l'envers et aux provinces on écoute
monsieur blanchet on écoute monsieur au
tour suivi de monsieur blanchet
je vais coordonnée avec promenait ce
logo et j'ai un budget dans notre plate
forme chiffrée et j'ai envoyé une lettre
qui a promené ce legault parce que c'est
très important pour moi d'avoir une
approche de respect pour le système au
québec et on va collaborer et quoi mener
avec le plat au québec et notre plein
avez vous vu quelque chose de nouveau
dans sa lette
exactement la mafia qui dit depuis le
début ça reste sur une auto ça reste les
conservateurs ça reste des valeurs qui
vont pas dans le sens de celle du québec
mais on dirait que les positions des
conservateurs bouge au gré des sondages
vous donner un conseil amical à monsieur
otto aussi vous pas trop ce sondage
les québécois sont préoccupés comme je
sais qu'ils le sont
par monsieur autour qui sont plaints de
nous ramener en arrière
c'est pas le bloc qui peut empêcher
un gouvernement conservateur on a besoin
que les québécois progressiste
choisissent un gouvernement progressiste
plein québécois prêt à lutter pour la
priorité à tous les jours et c'est ce
que nous sommes
l'appel au vote progrès c'est ce qui va
commencer ça va s'amplifier au cours des
prochains jours la part des libéraux
tour de table la question des garderies
néanmoins embête monsieur au tout depuis
le début avec l'électorat québécois
alain christien
c'est pas chiffré c'est pas clair
c'est ça le remarquer au moi je suis
monsieur blanchet peut-être que son
travail que moi mais moi en lisant la
lire que j'ai appris des choses c'est à
dire qu'elle est d'avoir su l'être c'est
écrit c'est un seul engagement c'est
assez rare et puis il dit spécifiquement
on reconnaît que le stand québec il si
ferradj d'europe on y parle je te dis un
risque c'est clair que ça veut pas dire
qu au fil d'arrivée le québec ma mort le
6 milliards mais moins qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai appris quelque chose que je savais
pas avant struth monsieur tous et puis
ça va c'est pour dire que la montée
devrait pas fulgurante mais
substantielle du bloc semble avant tout
nuire aux conservateurs au québec à rome
dans sa sont une espèce de deux mois de
compétition a eu plus d'effet que
monsieur legault je pense qu'on peut
dire c'est vrai je trouve ça c'est très
clair que le bloc a été galvanisé par le
dérapage du débat en anglais c'est clair
maintenant si monsieur s'était pas
produit peut-être que la pub monsieur
legault aura eu un effet positif pour
les conservateurs mais là clairement ça
c'est plus qu'annulé maintenant pour les
garderies je suis assez d'accord avec
monsieur blanchet souvenez vous lors du
débat que vous animiez
patrice les conservateurs disent agonie
prêt à collaborer avec le québec il y
avait déjà une ouverture mais
l'ouverture à peut pas être tellement
grande et d'après ce que j'en comprends
ce serait simplement pour la première
année la semaine dernière on parlait
d'un le jeu de 660 millions je pense on
est loin loin des 6 milliards parce que
les chiffres ont la tête dure dans son
cadre financier
on voit que l'économie qui fait c'est le
toutes les ententes que tout doit signer
avec les provinces et les enlève donc
pas les résultats je pense qu'il reste à
1.2 million un million pour tout le
monde exactement pour la première année
pour compenser martin monsieur legault a
pas dit un mot de cette lettre là
aujourd'hui fait visiblement ça va
moyennement d'importance pour lui
puisque ce qu'ils avaient dans la lettre
bon je savais le lendemain du débat et
monsieur août ou s'ils avaient voulu
marquer le coup sur cette question là
j'aurais été d'envoyer sa lettre dès le
lendemain du débat il me semble que ça
vient tard dans le débat alors que la
question déjà été soulevée le dès le
lendemain les partis d'opposition parler
du 6 milliards de monsieur
trudeau versus le 9 points 7 1 milliards
de monsieur autour le fonds michel aulas
dit tout à l'heure c'est que monsieur
legault il ya mieux monsieur o'toole qui
0 conditions santé de l'argent quitte à
perdre un peu d'argent des garderies
masi gérer et grappiller des choses à
droite qu'à gauche tous déjà patrice
sauvé sud ou est ouest mais oui mais
c'est super c'est pour cette raison que
à québec on en parle autant des
garderies parce que dans le fond les
lecteurs à québec qui lie et dans les
familles l'enjeu des garderies à québec
ça peut être très important parce que il
ya des parents qui ont pas qu'ils ont
pas de place il viole des négociations
sont sur le point avec le conseil du
trésor et les éducatrices et éducatrices
demande 12% le pardon les gouvernements
of 12% de rattrapage salarial les
éducatrices demande 27% et on dit dans
notre vie réelle ça va bouger à cet été
sur ce front là
il ya plusieurs conclusions
si vous avez bien résumé l'enjeu de tous
ceux très sain dans le débat public au
delà des résultats le titre est ce
qu'ils sont restés là prévoit secondo
québécois écoutent et loyaux l'argent il
ya le cash et les pouvoirs sasaki dit
parce que c'est ce qu'ils disent puis on
sache les paramètres qui oscille
électorale monsieur legault je me suis
je ne dis pas ça mais ce que je veux
dire c'est un niveau plus macropolitique
c'est un débat fondamental et c'est
parce que moi moi je prétends que une
des parties du vieux dit l'historique
cameco québec s'est construite on s'est
fait beaucoup exploité sur le plan
d'identité de façon honteuse on s'est
fait acheter une bonne partie clos ça
revient très bon dans son cher aux bulls
ebe conclusion oui alors mais moi je
pense que c'est strictement sur le plan
de l'argent monsieur monsieur au tour la
plus haute au talent et à terme que
monsieur trudeau malgré les malgré les
garderies et d'autre part mais c'est au
tour de bastien de goût il veut se
présenter à la prochaine élection en
disant regardez le mot j'ai un plan l'un
projet deuxième but puis j'ai fait
avancer les choses termine aussi trudeau
hypo vapor terminé merci vous trois très
bientôt au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit